the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
because some of this course was shot in
two different years two different
notation systems were used and I'm going
to explain both of them so that when you
encounter them in the videos of the
recitations or the videos of the
lectures you'll be able to use either of
the notation systems interchangeably so
the two notation systems with refer to
how we explain position vectors velocity
vectors and vectors of any kind that
might be associated with translating and
rotating reference frames so in this
diagram I've got a rigid body and
attached to that rigid body is a
reference frame I'll call it
X Y Z attached and moves with the body
and that's reference frame you know a
XYZ and the whole system is translating
and rotating in an inertial frame o
capital X capital y Capital Z and I need
to be able to describe the position and
the velocity of this rigid body and a
point on this rigid body which I'll call
B which might actually even be moving
with respect to the rigid body so the
position of this reference frame in
system 1 this is notation system 1 we
designate as R of a in reference frame o
and the O is the superscript that
precedes the are point B is R of B and O
and this vector is R of B with respect
to a and we write it B and with respect
to a is a superscript so this is
essentially the superscript version of
the notation we do the same thing in a
slightly different way in which we say
with respect to is a slash so
a with respect to frame o is written ra
/ o point b is RB / o and the vector
that goes from A to B is R of B / a so
the two are exactly equivalent and will
go one step farther and that is to take
the derivative the time derivative of
this vector B and use it to derive
expressions for velocities in a rotating
and translating frame the position RB
for example using this notation with
respect to O is our a with respect to O
plus RB with respect to a so it's just a
vector sum this vector Plus this vector
equals that vector and we want to take
the time derivative of this expression
for our B with respect to O and it will
give us an expression for the velocity
of point B with respect to the O frame
and here I've written this out in both
notation systems so in the notation
system where we use slash o as the with
respect to the velocity of B with
respect to O would be the velocity of
that frame translational velocity of a
with respect to O plus the time
derivative of the vector RB with respect
to a and that time derivative must be
taken in the inertial frame so / o this
term expands into two pieces so this all
this is equal to again V of a with
respect to O but now a derivative of R
be
a with respect to the a-frame this is as
if you were sitting on that rigid body
is that vector getting any longer or
shorter plus the rotation Omega of the
body with respect to O cross product
with RBA I've left out underscores here
to emphasize that these are vectors that
these are all vectors and in the
alternative notation system the slash
O's become superscripts so the velocity
of B and O is the velocity of a with
respect to O plus the the velocity as
seen from the point of view of being on
the rigid body Plus this is the
contribution to velocity as seen in the
inertial frame caused by the rotation of
the body and that's the two different
notation systems and you'll see these
used on solutions to problems you'll see
them in one or two of the 1 or either of
the two frames or either the two
notation systems and you will see these
notation systems used in lecture and in
these recitations